Dr. Syka Brown selected one brand Bouncy Ball
for testing, which came with its cardboard
label still attached.
The ball was placed in the machinery on the
"Fine" setting, and produced a ball with a
label identifying it as an "Extra Bouncy Ball."
This resulting ball was placed back in the
machine, once again on the "Fine" setting.
It produced a smaller ball, in a different
color, with a label calling it a "Super-Duper
Bouncy Ball."
This product does not appear to be sold in
stores.
The Super-Duper Bouncy Ball was placed in
914 on the setting "Very Fine".
No changes were made to its appearance, but
when Dr. Brown dropped the ball its resulting
bounce caused forty-five casualties and propelled
it out of the Earth's atmosphere.
Currently, it is orbiting near Mars.